this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer steven petty when mario golf
super rush is at its best
chaos is what makes it tick its many
unpredictable moments are delightfully
humorous
adding a new dimension to camelot's
long-running sports series
zany courses designed to look more like
3d super mario levels
and a pair of new fast-paced modes turn
the typically leisurely sport of golf
into an action game
super rush tries to add to its variety
even in its pair of control schemes
a button based swing system and motion
controls the button based control scheme
differs slightly from previous entries
this time around you click once to start
your swing accuracy is determined by
shift
marks outside of the meter that funnel
outward off the tee and in the fairway
the marks are confined to the top but
when you have a bad lie
they start much lower making it less
likely to hit your shots on target
super rush's button based swing system
rewards finding the short grass
motion controls on the other hand hark
back to the simplicity of wii sports
unfortunately this doesn't really work
when playing super rush's tricky courses
four swings are manageable
but any shot that requires a delicate
swing is too much of a guessing game
it was immediately clear that motion
controls were simply incompatible with
the elaborate designs
camelot created to highlight the new
leading game mode of
golf that said mastering the three click
swing system including shaping the golf
ball
adding backspin and tinkering with
trajectories is more important than ever
because the courses are littered with
obstacles which also make you think more
about the type of shot you want to hit
in speed golf you're racing to finish
each hole as fast as you can
each shot adds 30 seconds to your time
so you need to try to play well
while maintaining a brisk pace
speedgolf adds a new layer of strategy
and chaos since everyone plays
simultaneously
an unfortunate downside to speedgolf is
that you can never admire your good
shots
because you're running down the fairway
towards your ball battle golf uses the
mechanics of speed golfs and cranks up
the mayhem
it pits up to four players against each
other in a stadium course with nine
flags to aim at
the first player to secure three flags
wins the twist here
is that once a flag is claimed it's gone
from the game battle golf emphasizes
both skill
and strategy there are two layouts
available one that's fairly
straightforward and another that's
littered with enemies obstacles and
hazards
due to its design battlegolf conjures up
even more random chaos than speed golf
making it an optimal party game with
lightning quick rounds that never have a
dull moment
each of the 16 playable characters are
equipped with a pair of moves that can
be deployed strategically in these
fast-paced modes special shot and super
dash for instance
wario's special shot creates lightning
strikes that toy with your shots
yoshi rolls around on a giant egg when
dashing while charging chuck looks like
a fullback trying to mow down the
competition
each golfer's unique super dash can help
them to get to the ball faster
but it also can be a deterrent for
competitors progress since you can knock
opponents down while running
meanwhile a well timed and placed
special shot can knock other golfers
balls from a good position to a not
ideal spot
these two central mechanics often look
cool in motion and are incredibly useful
in speed golf
it's clear why speedgolf rules mario
golf super rush when you step onto the
links
with the exception of two traditional
courses that look like golf courses
you'd find in real life
super rush's courses teeter between
absurd and diabolical
and i say this as a compliment ridge
rock lake is set along cliffs surrounded
by water and features broiders rolling
across fairways
typhus guarding greens and wind tunnels
that can send you and your ball up to
another level there's a lot of fun
strategy involved here thanks to the
elevation changes
and the scattered layout
[Music]
balmy dunes a desert themed course with
towering pokies
giant sand mars surrounding the fairways
quicksand and elevation changes galore
is a sprawling track that works
wonderfully for speed golf
because of the enemy placement barmy
dunes often forces you to get creative
with shots
hitting fades around pokies and high
launching shots over those pesky sand
mars
another course wild weather woods uses
unpredictable conditions to mess with
your game randomized spots on the course
are prone to lightning strikes if you
swing your club too far back
costing you a stroke and precious time
meanwhile biddy buds waddle across the
fairway and piranha creepers poke their
chompy heads out
requiring you to zigzag to your ball the
final course bowser highlands
is a molten themed track with lava
bubbles emerging from the fiery depth
magmas creeping over the edge of danger
bombs whomps and chain chomps scattered
across the fairways
and fireballs circling platforms you
need to cross it's the most perilous
course of the bunch due to the sheer
number of hazards and obstacles
making for a fitting swan song
nice shot
even though super rush features some of
the best courses in series history
it's a tad underwhelming to only have
six at release especially since two of
them
though great for traditional golf
purists feel like standard mario golf
fare
though nintendo has vowed to release
free post launch content for super rush
world tour for 3ds had 10 courses at
launch to unlock all of the clever and
playful courses
you have to work your way through golfer
adventure as your me as the tempo
game mode golf adventure isn't the fully
fledged role-playing golf journey it
seems to be from the outset
it offers very little besides a primer
to what super rush is all about
despite the semi-open world layout with
hubs for each course and
npc scattered throughout super rush's
world feels shallow
with nothing to do besides the next main
line event golfer adventure doesn't even
allow you to use motion controls
probably because you'd have a hard time
reaching credits as a rookie working
towards becoming a golf superstar you
earn badges that unlock new tournaments
and courses
what's particularly strange about golf
adventures challenges is that you only
ever play a full
18 hole round one time it's often
segmented into smaller challenges
where you have to shoot better than a
certain score or under time restraints
and almost the entire roughly six hour
campaign center is on speed golf
you only play short spurts of
traditional golf and never in a
tournament
round like mario tennis aces there are a
few boss battles each of which utilize
the mechanics in fun ways
even if they are short-lived duels the
lackluster golf adventure does have a
few standout challenges at least
ridge rock lake's cross country golf
event tasks you with completing nine
holes in under 40 strokes but you get to
choose which order to complete the holes
in which adds some welcome strategy to
the breezy mode
bowser highlands is also markedly
different in golf adventure
as it mixes fire and ice holes the snowy
holes feature ice bros
sliding freezies and other super mario
staples the mix between fire and ice
makes bowser highlands feel like two
courses sandwiched into one which winds
up making a really interesting course
that sadly can't be played outside of
golf adventure
unfortunately ai controlled golfers are
absolutely horrendous in golf adventure
not just in the beginning but all
throughout the campaign this presents an
issue since speedgolf requires you to
wait for your opponents to finish the
hole before moving on to the next
watching pink yoshi turn away from the
flag stick and chunk yet another shot
into the rough after you're already done
gross tiresome
and watching insert any character name
actively aim away from the hole on a
perfectly straight puck can become
infuriating
the biggest blunder of golf adventure is
that once the credit rolls there's
nothing really left to do
you can go back and level up your
character and round out your set of golf
clubs
but it's not even possible to replay
certain sections of the game golfer
adventure doesn't even track any of your
best scores so there isn't
any real reason to do so anyway there is
a separate solo challenge mode that
keeps track of your best scores
but it seems like a weird decision to
not roll this into an end game for golf
adventure
like many sports games mario golf super
rush's legs come from multiplayer
against real humans
whether they be online or locally when
playing locally up to four golfers can
jump into standard golf but only two can
play at a time in battle golf and speed
golf
it should be noted that ai golfers play
markedly better outside of golf
adventure which makes playing a round of
speed golf against the computer much
more fun than in golf adventure
with three radically different styles of
play and some seriously inventive
courses
mario golf super rush is a compellingly
original sports game
speed golf and battle golf actively make
you adapt to wild different conditions
while balancing technique and speediness
the three click swing system still feels
great
though if you desire an accurate motion
controlled golf game this isn't it
golfer adventure curiously lacks a
conventional tournament structure
or record keeping making it a tough sell
to revisit
super rush isn't the best entry in the
series
but it is a worthy addition
[Music]
nice
[Music]